there's Johnny it's Johnny from the
shining guys I'm Greg I'm Johnny
we're gonna watch doctor we did watch it
we're gonna review Chuck your sleep
today this takes place I believe 40
years after the events of the shining
Danny Torrance is all grown up and he
looks like Ewan McGregor now yep what
did he look great dude so rough when he
cleans up if you've seen the trailer for
this movie you know the Overlook Hotel
is still around and I'm saying that
because in the shining book the Overlook
Hotel spoilers if you're reading on
reading the book it's different in the
movie the Overlook still around in the
book the Overlook Hotel is blown up as
you see in the trailer the Overlook
Hotel still is around showing that this
is gonna be a hybrid of both the sequel
to the Stanley Kubrick version plus an
adaptation of the Stephen King novel of
the same name I was really looking for
to this movie Mike Flanagan directed
edited wrote did the catering service
starred in it he played all the roles so
impress is all the extras - yeah I'm a
big fan of his work love doll haunting a
Hell House oculus is gray Gerald's game
hush I had a lot of high hopes for this
movie as I thought like the he would be
the perfect person to continue this and
I have a feeling that John and I will be
in the minority on certain things I saw
that it has a pretty good Rotten
Tomatoes critic score but a very high
audience score so I imagine that there's
gonna be some things we say that people
will just disagree with but we gots to
be honest we gots to be awesome to be
real Stephen King chills Stephen King
sucks guys let me tell you something
about Steve King being real King's great
for starters I like this a lot more than
a chapter two just gonna get that out of
the way yes the things that are solidly
great for starters even McGregor as a
grown up Danny Torrance
that is a very lived in performance one
thing that you can count on Mike
Flanagan he's gonna give a lot of
attention to detail on his characters
and really give a personal growth
journey his character's haunted by his
past obviously now that he's older he
whatever he can to repress or limit the
use of his shine he's also a struggling
alcoholic even McGregor I just thought
really captivated every layer to this
performance and I thought it was
beautifully done and there were moments
where I was like he does kind of look
like and he has this especially when he
uses an American accent he has a very
boyish quality to him or at least it
reads to me and so in a sense since we
all know Danny so well as a child I felt
like he was actually a really nice
casting choice yes especially for the
things that he's been through and the
kind of softness that's in Danny I
thought he really brought that out the
villain in this movie is played by
Rebecca Ferguson she plays the the Mad
Hatter originally played by Johnny Depp
Rose the Hat Rose the Hat half of this
movie is from beginning to end is
dedicated to rose in this cult that she
has but not basically what they do is
they feed off of the the shine and they
specifically hunt down people once in a
while who possess this ability and they
feed off of whatever energy that gives
them and they're able to live for a very
long time there are some cool members in
that group but I lost a cast of haunting
of Hill House characters I really
recognize Rebecca Ferguson though every
time she's on screen she steals a spot
she's terrific she really really does
shine hahaha she's great there's some
wonderful visual moments in here I like
when Mike Flanagan gets weird with his
visuals because he doesn't do that a lot
he uses that sparingly and he chooses
the appropriate moments to do it because
it's not like throughout but when he
does it it's very very effective I
thought that was great and to me the
best part of this movie this is a two
and a half hour film there was like 45
minutes of setup it's a lot of set of
big there's the middle chunk in this
movie and then of course the finale 3x
structure right kinds of countries like
a six extra adapted from a lot of source
materials so it the structure is
definitely not typical we both felt like
this probably needed to be a miniseries
especially because of what Mike Flanagan
did with haunting of Hill House I do
no if it this comes down to comparison
in some ways I don't know how seeped
into my brain that is because there's so
much similarities to what's cleaning
sport here in haunting of Hill House I
was like that's a perfect show yeah and
then I watch this and I'm like there's
so much happening and it's moving so
fast that kind of threw me off because
especially coming off of Kubrick's The
Shining which is very deliberately paced
and then just knowing Mike Flanagan's
work very deliberately paced the first
45 minutes of this film I thought was
kind of jarring and in an unusual way it
just seemed like he was moving so fast
and we were recovering so much ground
and the way the scenes ended didn't
really feel like they ended it seems you
should usually have a beginning middle
and end as well and I felt like a lot of
the scenes had a beginning a middle and
then we fade beginning middle dissolve
there's a like this movie has an
obnoxious amount of dissolve and fade
throughout oh you rarely cuts to another
scene it's constantly fade structure of
scenes became here's a little setup or a
nugget of information and a button in a
transition and yeah that's kind of how
everything moved along and that's partly
why the movie started to come apart to
me is because there were times where I
could really feel like okay this is
written to be a two-minute senior or you
know like a 60 second scene with a quick
transition the elements start to come
apart to me really early if you've seen
haunting of Hill House so much of the
subject matter and the metaphor is the
same you have Mike Flanagan's overall
visual aesthetic so for me I felt like I
was watching a weird hill house light
clip Smedley know it's like when they
adapt like a show into a movie or a mini
slept a miniseries into a movie yeah it
felt like stilted in a weird way and so
I either felt like yeah this either
should have been really pared down as a
story or made into a miniseries because
especially like the Luke character is
practically Danny for half this I mean
granted Stephen King adaptations often
have this criticism a lot of certain
here and I will say that even though it
had suppers I think from the same issue
and like I said maybe a lot of people in
a group us on that I think it's better
than a lot of those other ones you know
layout DCI and it's conscientious about
what it's doing I feel like you can feel
certain elements of the studio know it's
like I feel like this is kind of at war
with itself because to me this read like
it came out of the time that is giving
us these big legacy follow-ups so this
reminded me of like let's make it more
like an it where it's got a gloss
and it's got a sorta Hollywood
blockbuster quality or a conjuring s
quality same you know studio exactly it
reminded me of Terminator dark fate in
the way that it seems like they're not
actually emulating the type of film that
the original film was and so that
affects the way the whole film moves and
breathes well that's what I mean he's at
war with himself in a weird way because
he has to do the Kubrick sequel and the
adaptation of the King novel where King
is very you know public about how he
doesn't like the Kubrick version because
it doesn't feel at all like how he
imagined it to be the middle portion of
this movie is really what you see in the
trailer you got away like close to an
hour before the stuff in the trailer the
plot set up like the real plot of this
movie kicks in cults the not hearing
about this little girl who has like this
really advanced shine ability and then
Danny sort of protecting and guiding her
and somehow this is gonna link to
getting us back to the Overlook Hotel
this middle chunk like the part of the
trailer that that had that they
advertise I really like that that's
where the cool visuals come in there's
some violent stuff that goes down then I
was pretty surprised of how much I'm not
like overly surprised but with a big
studio film I was like wow they're
really committed to that there are
moments yet in the middle that are truly
horrific and when you get to have the
mystery still like the problem is when
the movie starts answering questions it
starts to take the tension out but in
the middle part you have the not as this
really evil monstrous group and for a
moment there you're able to be like oh
God how are they gonna take these guys
these guys seem horrible you have also
the growing relationship between abre
and Danny from a distance which is
really cool and kind of heartfelt in a
way and the actual title sake of the
movie which is Danny's ability when it
comes to helping people on their last
moments of life you know those are the
most interesting things in the movie I
felt like there was a lot explored then
there's a lot of stuff in that first 45
minutes that is set up that I don't
actually think is paid off well to give
some teasers of that there's this blonde
character named they they calls a snake
bite and II she has his cool power they
set her up and they really don't do much
with her when she joins the team she's
just there there's there's like there's
definitely hi spoiler moments that we
can't go into bruce greenwood there's
this exchange
it happens with Danny Torrance very
early on that you think is gonna lead
somewhere perhaps a little investigative
or suspicious but nothing becomes of
that Italy to anything even the doctor
sleep stuff doesn't really factor into
the main movie not enough to justify
yeah yeah it feels like an interlude
it's more of a thing that occurs i guess
one could argue that it helps serve the
journey of Danny Torrance ultimately
with exploring where he is sure yeah
absolutely upset but that's why I think
a lot of this probably would work better
in a miniseries or Matt this movie
successfully ties its themes together
when it wants to but it doesn't have
enough time to flesh them any without
spoiling anything I put out a tweet
today and I tweeted Ryan George a pitch
meeting specifically about this moment
the thing that kicks this plot into high
gear how the cults essentially that what
causes this circumstance to happen and
you could you could read my tweet if you
don't want to get spoiled for you the
second it happened of how they managed
to obtain a certain person in the middle
of the movie I literally looked to my
girlfriend and I was like super easy
like the most major thing to pivot this
movie this was such a convenient thing
it was weird to me with the whole
shining stuff because that's what I
thought the movie kind of got at some of
its weakest and yet most interesting I
thought when they finally got to the
Overlook Hotel it was earned because the
movie is long and it takes a long time
to get there and I thought you know what
yeah like cool we're here I'm excited
now you're returning to Hill House
exactly and I call that in the trailer
like you literally could restate Hill
House in the shining and it would work
when they were there though admittedly I
was under tained a lot of it kind of
reminded me what they did would ready
player one if you've seen that movie as
much as I thought they earned getting to
the Overlook I kind of felt like they
suddenly started doing a bunch of what I
can only describe as like fanservice and
greatest hits of The Shining wrapped up
in like 20 minutes in this movie I think
sums it up really well and if you don't
want a minor moment spoiled skip the
next 20 seconds the blood comes out of
the
elevators Rebecca Ferguson's walking by
and she just looks we cut back to the
blood she's like it's like that's how
this movie country clearly wasn't there
and and so that's kind of the essence of
this movie to me is like there's yeah
there is that horrifying like it is cool
to go back to the shining but at the
same time we don't really get to live in
it we just kind of get to walk past all
of it like it's still a character-driven
story so there are moments in the hotel
that I thought were really great and
that made a lot of sense because there's
so much about compartmentalization and
setting up boxes in your mind to keep
certain traumatic things inside and
cycles of abuse as need to be broken
this is like the big studio version of
things Mike Flanagan has explored I like
the movie I don't love the movie I kind
of just felt a little hollow there are
big moments that should feel like poetic
sweepingly emotional and yet I never
felt much towards that the music
provides all the torque for that it's
not scary to me and not that it
necessarily needs to be but a you know
in case you're wondering it's not scary
it ought to be tense there's so much
potential and that's this like there are
moments I was like this could there were
like sequences out of a
two-and-a-half-hour movie that felt
suspenseful but most of it wasn't
halfway through the film there's
something that happens with Rose the
hack character and Rebecca Ferguson from
beginning to end is wonderful for
performance however she really is not a
threat there's something this movie does
as it keeps going you're just like
there's no threat to compare to the
shining which this movie lends itself to
you're scared of Jack Nicholson he's
good he's just gonna keep getting worse
and it's scary and the hotel everything
yeah the whole place is just oppressive
and horrifying but our main villain is
not a threat abundantly clear that most
of this movie sheet you're like I'm not
scared for her I feel like a little girl
who is good I mean I have some issues
with the writing but she's good little
girl and you McGregor probably I gotta
have a issue the whole time well in that
plotline I feel like is is something
that is indicative of what we're trying
to figure out in modern film right now
because his relationship with Abra I
thought was really nice idea and I love
the concept of how it developed and I
think we're still figuring out on this
blockbuster scale how to handle
empowered characters like this you're
young female empowered Lee
because there's also a lot of tension
that I think could have happened with
more time to have a more character drive
for her because Abra is kind of slighted
by the lack of tension coming off of
rows the Hat they don't quite write her
as a lived-in character quite as much as
a lot of the other characters there are
so many of these legacy projects coming
out now that are like maddening for how
all right they are and I feel that for
this but I do think this is one of the
better if not the best ones in recent
memory because it still manages to have
a good amount of character thrust and at
least coherently ties themes together it
has things you can compare to the world
even things that I wasn't expecting like
you know uh abusers in power and the
people speaking out to them like in
subtle ways so I appreciate what this
movie is trying to do but it's just so
frustrating because like it's all the
potential is there and it's hurt by its
format I think I think a lot people when
they saw the trailer for this including
ourselves thought they were just
throwing in footage from The Shining but
apparently that was all reshot and this
movie makes them very early on like from
the beginning of this movie you're like
oh never mind this is uh recreated so
with that the cast actors to play these
you know essentially iconic horror
character the performers are good I have
no issues with them I had have staged
those different though at times though
it is just distracting because of the
context like you can't really win some
we're doing The Shining yeah we're
inside the shining right now this is
crazy I mean you just can't really win
sometimes when they're trying to embody
the performance of characters back then
you know when we live in a very
self-conscious - like that we saw this
on the heels of that James Dean
announcement it's weird cuz I was like
I'm psyched that you got actual actors
to recreate this but at the same time it
is still distracting you can't win like
you can't win with da G and you can't
win with putting other actors in there
either way it's distracting either way
it calls attention to what they're doing
yeah it always calls attention it's
still like that middle chunk even in the
first 45 minutes in the finale that's
where a lot of the I think the flow tone
issues kind of come into play you know
it's better than most and I still like
it I'll give it like a solid 3 in and
3.2 5 out of 5 stars
I'll give it three and a half for the 5
hour cut I know is probably better than
this alright guys well did you see dr.
sleep as you like it
would you have change do you think that
there is an extended cut out there you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell we'll catch
you guys soon